So let's look at our answer
to the UMA/SMP quiz.
We want to have a lot of cores
with this type of architecture,
so what are the problems
that we'll have to face?
The memory will need to be large and
slow.
And that's because having more
cores usually means that we will be
running programs that access more data.
And we need to keep the data somewhere,
so we will need to have a large memory.
And that makes the memory slow.
Next, that memory will get too
many accesses per second because
the cache misses from all of
the cores will be going to memory.
If one of the cores generates cache
misses that he memory can survive doing.
Two of them, it might still survive.
But if we have a lot of cores our
memory will probably not be able to
keep up with all of those accesses.
We'll need a lot of small memory
modules, not necessarily.
The number of memory modules in
a centralized memory doesn't matter.
What is really needed is
to have enough memory for
all the cores to get
enough data in there and
the memory that will keep up with
the bandwidth demands of the cores.
How many modules we have
doesn't really matter.
Caches will have very small block size.
This is not true either.
All of the caches and all the cores
can have any block size they want.
The block size is not
divided among the cores.
Pages for
virtual memory become too small.
Same thing.
We can have any page size we want.
Having more or fewer cores doesn't
affect the page size in virtual memory.
So, the only options you should
have selected are the first two.